[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie wär's mit einem kleinen
gedankenexperiment stellen unternehmen
vor dessen jahresumsatz die
wirtschaftskraft der länder also ihre
kompletten volkswirtschaften übertrifft
ein unternehmen das mehr als 10 prozent
der globalen erdölproduktion und mehr
ölreserven kontrolliert als jedes andere
land mit ausnahme eines fehlers was
meint ihr
welch exorbitante macht hätte ein
solcher koloss es wäre die größte
business machtmaschine aller zeiten
ein megakonzern der in der lage wäre die
gesamte weltwirtschaft zu verändern eine
einzige sitzung des vorstands dieser
firma während wichtiger und
schwerwiegender als entscheidungen
ganzer staaten und deren demokratisch
gewählte regierung
solide form von visual politik ließ
hörmann von der hier die rede ist
existiert tatsächlich und sie ist vor
kurzem an die börse gegangen
das unternehmen dass wir meinen ist
genau saudi aramco
ok ihr habt vielleicht noch nicht davon
gehört aber diese unternehmen
kontrolliert und bewirtschaftet so gut
wie alle erdölfelder in saudi arabien
[Musik]
die marktkapitalisierung dieses
unternehmens gegangen beträgt fast zwei
billionen dollar und kann gewinne von
mehr als 100 milliarden dollar pro jahr
erwirtschaften
zum vergleich das ist mehr als die summe
der gewinne der nächsten fünf größten
privaten ölkonzerne der welt
zusammengenommen der abstand zur
konkurrenz ist gewaltig wie du hier
sehen kannst
[Musik]
darüber hinaus ist ramco auch einer der
größten petrochemie und brachte in der
rhi konzern er kontrolliert raffinerien
in der ganzen welt darunter die größte
ölraffinerie in den vereinigten staaten
auf entscheidungen rund um den schritt
für unsere autos hat dieses unternehmen
fast so viel oder sogar mehr einfluss
als unsere regierung was genau steckt
also hinter diesen unternehmen warum hat
saudi arabien sein kronjuwel auf den
markt gebracht und wie weitreichend die
tentakel dieser konzerne riesenkrake
wenn ihr das alles erfahren wollt hört
jetzt gut zu der börsengang am 11
dezember 2009 10 wurde der handel mit
aktien der saudi aramco oil company an
der saudi-arabischen börse inter da wohl
aufgenommen
[Musik]
die saudische regierung bot den
aktionären dabei noch nicht mal ganze 15
prozent ihrer aktien an
[Musik]
aber das war immer noch genug für den
größten ipo aller zeiten
insgesamt gingen dabei aramco aktien
führt 25,6 milliarden dollar über den
ladentisch mit diesem geld werden die
kassen des staatlichen investmentfonds
mit saudi arabien gefüttert damit dieser
es in unternehmen und branchen jenseits
des öl business investieren kann
denn das ist das ziel eine
diversifikation der saudischen
geldquelle schaut fast alle länder am
persischen golf die im grunde neue öl
und gas fördern versuchen die verrückt
ihre wirtschaft zu diversifizieren und
damit ihre abhängigkeit vom verkauf
dieser rohstoffe zu verringern aber
nicht jeder dieser staaten befindet sich
in der gleichen situation für einige
dieser länder wie kuwait katar oder die
vereinigten arabischen emirate besteht
in dieser angelegenheit weit weniger
handlungsdruck
immerhin verfügen sie wie wir euch auf
diesem kanal bereits erklärt haben über
gewaltige ressourcen gewaltige
geldreserven und eine im vergleich dazu
relativ kleine bevölkerungszahl die lage
in saudi arabien jedoch sieht ganz
anders aus das land des hauses sound
verfügt zwar über riesige öl reserven
die zweitgrößten der welt nach wenn es
wäre aber das problem ist dass seine
bevölkerungszahl nichts mit der groß
oder der emirate vergleichbar ist das
heißt pro kopf sind die ressourcen saudi
arabiens viel viel kleiner
[Musik]
und nicht nur das die bevölkerung saudi
arabiens ist im schnitt sehr jung und
weist seit jahren eine der höchsten
geburtenraten oder allen ländern der
welt auf wir sprechen von einem land in
dem 40 prozent der bevölkerung unter 25
jahren alt sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit 1950 hat sich die einwohnerzahl von
3 5 millionen auf heute über 34
millionen verzehnfacht
und ja in der vergangenheit konnten sich
die saudis dank ihren übrigen
öleinnahmen praktisch alle möglichen
wohltaten leisten die ihnen in den sinn
kamen große städte bauprojekte
kostenlose bildung und
gesundheitsfürsorge öffentlich
arbeitsplätze garantiertes einkommen für
jedermann und so weiter
da nun jedoch ein durchaus erheblicher
teil der bevölkerung in ein
fortgeschrittenes alter rückt
kompliziert sich die situation für die
regierung immer mehr da ihr
stadthaushalt ein immer größer werdendes
systematisches problem beinhaltet
welches mittlerweile zu einem
haushaltsdefizit von jährlich fast 50
milliarden dollar geführt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das ist nur 50 milliarden dollar
wurden konnte erst mit biegen und
brechen nach mehreren kürzungsrunde der
einführung neuer steuern und letzten
endes durch eine glückliche fügung
nämlich eine starke erholung des
ölpreises am weltmarkt erreicht werden
und trotz alldem beträgt das minus noch
immer 50 milliarden dollar pro jahr
und genau da kommt einer der großen
protagonisten dieser geschichte ins
spiel
der kronprinz mohammed bin salman der
mittlerweile das land regiert
[Musik]
im januar 2016 kündigten mohamed bin
hammam 5% von arango an der börse
verkaufen zu wollen um sein programm
vision 2030 zu finanzieren ein plan der
ein ziel verfolgt wenn ich die enorme
abhängigkeit des landes vom erdöl zu
senken
fast 70 prozent aller einnahmen der
saudischen regierung und 80 prozent der
exporte saudi arabiens hängen von diesem
rohstoff ab darüber hinaus muss man
verstehen dass in saudi arabien so gut
wie jede wirtschaftsleistung und
wirtschaftsaktivität die außerhalb der
ölbranche erbracht wird weitgehend am
tropf der öffentlichen hand hängt das
heißt ohne subventionen und
staatsaufträge nicht konkurrenz und
existenz die ich wäre
[Musik]
um das geld für diese subvention und
staatsaufträge stammt wie herum zu fast
100 aus ich hab's erraten öleinnahmen
mit anderen worten es ist sehr schwer
einen sektor der saudi-arabischen
wirtschaft zu finden der nicht auf die
eine oder andere weise zum verkauf
millionen jahre alten unterirdischen
kohlenwasserstoffe abhängig ist
bei der gesamten wirtschaftsraum die
arabiens handelt es sich also quasi um
einen suchtkranken süchtig nach
schwarzen gold ein geradezu
pathologischen junkie und natürlich wird
diese abhängigkeit zu einem immer größer
werdenden probleme in einer welt wird
immer mehr öl produzenten in der das
fracking zu einem sehr wichtigen rivalen
geworden ist und in einer welt in der
aus sorge um die klimaerwärmung eine
verringerung des globalen ölverbrauchs
eine wahrlich realistisches szenario
werden könnte wenn wir nun auch noch
berücksichtigen dass die junge und
verwöhnte saudische bevölkerung sehr
hohe erwartungen an ihren lebensstandard
hat muss das land eindeutig nach
alternativen suchen um sich diesen
lebensstandard auch leisten zu können
und genau diese absicht steckt hinter
dem schrittweisen verkauf von anteilen
an aramco mit dem geld aus dem
verkaufserlös sollen andere projekte
finanziert werden neue arbeitsplätze
geschaffen und die abhängigkeit des
landes von öl verringert werden aber wie
wir alle nur zu gut wissen ist der weg
in die hölle in der regel mit guten
absichten gepflastert was meinst du kann
man den börsengang von aramco als einen
erfolg ansehen man könnte leicht zu
diesem schluss kommen immerhin hat die
saudische regierung daraus ein
verkaufserlös von mehr als 25 milliarden
dollar erhalten nun falls du auch dieser
meinung bist liegst du verdammt falsch
trotz der großspurigen schlagzeilen die
du eventuell in den medien lesen
konntest verlief der börsengang von
aramco alles andere als glatt
unkompliziert und erfolgreich aber sehen
wir uns die ganze geschichte mal etwas
aus der nähe an
das größte unternehmen der welt
durch den börsengang ist aramco zum
wertvollsten börsennotierten unternehmen
der welt geworden
tatsächlich hat der marktwert innerhalb
weniger tage nach dem handelsbeginn die
zwei billionen dollar marke
überschritten
arango schätzung erreicht den vom
kronprinzen angestrebten wertvolle 2
billionen dollar
wall street das sind sage und schreibe
2000 milliarden oder zwei millionen
millionen dollar
aber moment mal wenn wir die
hintergründe der ganzen geschichte
untersuchen
sieht alles ganz anders aus zum
zeitpunkt als mohammed bin salman mit
seinen börsenplänen das erste mal an die
öffentlichkeit ging wollte er das aramco
an einer der großen weltbörsen wie new
york london oder hongkong gelistet
damit jeder aktieninvestor weltweit über
einen optimalen zugang zu handeln mit
aramco aktien verfügt und nicht nur das
er beabsichtigte 5 prozent der masse
verkaufen und damit mindestens 100
milliarden dollar verkaufserlös zu
erzielen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und was blieb am ende von diesen
großspurigen leben übrig die investoren
kauften ihn nur 1,5 prozent der aktien
ab das heißt gerade mal ein drittel der
angestrebten zahl
außerdem erhalten alle großen globalen
börsenplätze den saudis eine abfuhr
also die ihnen nichts anderes übrig als
die neuen aktien an der landeseigenen
börse tata wohl in riad zu platzieren wo
diese spielt an den globalen
finanzmärkten eher eine unbedeutende
rolle so jetzt fragt ihr euch sicher was
in aller welt denn passieren konnte so
dass diese vermeintliche traum story der
mächtigsten firma der welt als ein
derartiger reinfall zu ende gehen nun
überraschenderweise ist dies recht
schnell erklärt die listung an einer der
großen weltbörsen ist an zwei wichtige
bedingungen geknüpft
[Musik]
zum einen verlangen diese märkte ein
hohes maß an transparenz und die
einhaltung vieler vorschriften zb den
schutz von kleinanlegern und das kann
für eine der absichtlich und durch
wichtigsten der welt die seit jahren ein
selbstbedienungsladen der saudischen
königsfamilie ist ein ziemlich großes
problem darstellen
transparenz kann nun mal einen
kulturschock darstellen für eine
regierung die es gewohnt ist zu tun was
sie will
wann sie es will und wie sie ist will
ohne jemandem in irgendeiner form
rechenschaft ablegen zu müssen und zum
anderen gab es ein noch viel größeres
problem von dem es erst recht kein
entkommen gab die saudische regierung
musste der harten war hat in die augen
sehen dass der markt einfach nicht
bereit war das zu bezahlen was sie für
arm co gerne verlangt hätte ja auf der
einen seite mag es sich um den grössten
ölkonzern der welt mit den niedrigsten
förderkosten handeln aber auf der
anderen seite wird dieses unternehmen
noch immer von einem der autoritären und
strengsten regimes der welt kontrolliert
barranco sollte gegenüber den
internationalen öl giganten er mit einem
rabatt als mit einem aufschlag gehandelt
werden wir bewerten saudi aramco als
underperformer analysten von ernst ihnen
in der financial times
und vergesst nicht dass wir hier auch
über den nahen osten sprechen eine von
permanenter instabilität und spannung
geprägt region in welcher es gar nicht
außergewöhnlich ist nachrichten wie
folgendes zu lesen
mai 2009 10 saudische öl pipeline bald
drohnenangriff durch hut die rebellen
beschädigt kampfdrohnen erzwangen die
abschaltung der pipelines
schon kurz zuvor war auf zwei öltanker
des landes ein anschlag verübt worden
wall street
ganz zu schweigen von der katastrophalen
lage der öffentlichen finanzen des
landes
denn was auch immer passieren wird die
wahrheit ist ganz einfach dass saudi
aramco weiterhin die saudische regierung
finanzieren wird nicht nur mit
dividenden sondern auch über hohe
steuerzahlungen so wurde der gewinn von
aramco früher mit 50 bis 85 prozent
besteuert um den anlegern den börsengang
schmackhaft zu machen kündigte die
regierung an den gewinnsteuersatz für
aramco auf nur 20 prozent zu senken
aber wer weiß wie lange sie dieses
versprechen auch einhalten kann
denn mit diesem einbruch bei den
steuereinnahmen gehen ihre übrigen
zahlen einfach nicht mehr auf und woher
können die anleger wissen dass die
saudische regierung mit ihrem aktuellen
minus von 50 milliarden dollar in
zukunft bei noch stärkeren
haushaltsdefiziten nicht einfach wieder
das macht was sie in der vergangenheit
schon immer getan hat nämlich die koralm
co weiter zu melden bei einem
niedrigeren niveau der ölpreise kann
erwartet werden dass der staat
möglicherweise die steuern erhöht das
versprechen die höhe der dividenden
zahlungen an nichtstaatliche aktionäre
aufrecht zu erhalten ist rechtlich nicht
unantastbar
dimitri mariko senior director bei fitch
ratings
[Musik]
nun all diese faktoren haben dazu
geführt dass internationale investoren
viel weniger geld geboten haben als es
die saudische regierung erwartet hat und
das obwohl das unternehmen sein großes
indianer ehrenwort gab mindestens 75
milliarden dollar pro jahr an dividenden
ausschütten zu wollen
es waren also diese schlechten
bewertungen die sie dazu zwangen stadt
bei der weltmeisterschaft nur in der
kreisliga anzutreten und wisst ihr was
der börsengang in riad war dann auch ein
paradebeispiel dafür wie die dinge in
diesen ländern nun mal laufen wie
geschmiert ein nicht wie geschmiert
sondern geschmiert schwierig um ihr
erstes aktienpaket überhaupt loszuwerden
mussten die arabien mehr doping
betreiben als russland bei allen
olympischen spielen zusammen genommen
so hat die regierung beispielsweise
großunternehmen empfohlen aktien von
arango zu kaufen oder die konsequenz zu
tragen
eine empfehlung die man in saudi arabien
nun mal nicht abschlagen kann
dazu setzten sie sogar verbündete
staaten wie die vereinigten arabischen
emirate und kuwait unter druck um für
milliarden von dollar in aktien von
aramco zu investieren sonst wer weiß und
die banken mussten kredite mit extrem
niedrigen zinssätzen an kleinanleger
vergeben damit für diese der erwerb von
arango aktien attraktiv wurde eine
marketingkampagne gewaltigen ausmaßes
wurde ausgerollt das heißt die saudische
regierung tat wirklich alles in ihrer
macht stehende um den börsengang zum
erfolg zu verhelfen oder zumindest so
tun zu können als ob es ein erfolg
gewesen wäre denn am ende unserer
geschichte lieben die meisten aktien zu
hause dh in saudi arabien und die
saudische wirtschaft ist nach wie vor
genauso abhängig von der ölförderung wie
zuvor und das umso mehr als jetzt nicht
nur der staat sondern auch das schicksal
vieler familien und kleinanleger in
saudi arabien mit dem schicksalhaften
aramco steht und fällt
[Musik]
das was sie ursprünglich vorhatten
nämlich ausländisches kapital ins land
zu holen
tun sie gar nicht mehr es handelt sich
nicht um ein reales geschäft sondern nur
noch politik ein leitender banker darum
bat nicht identifiziert zu werden im
gespräch mit der financial times
[Musik]
die frage die wir uns jetzt stellen
müssen lautet sind mohammed bin zweimal
pläne vollends gescheitert klar ist
jedenfalls dass dieser versuch eines
weltweiten absatzes von arango aktien
vor allem deutlich gemacht hat wie es in
saudi arabien tatsächlich zugeht
saudi arabien ist eines jener länder in
denen immer das getan wird was die
regierung will und das ist ausländische
investoren nicht gerade das attraktivste
klima
[Musik]
dieses gewaltige problem zeigte sich
erneut als im märz 2020 inmitten der
korona krise die sowieso schon den öl
absatz und damit den ölpreis mächtig
nach unten drückte saudi arabien einen
preiskrieg mit russland und den usa vom
zaun brach und den ölpreis zum totalen
einsturz brachte
größter ölpreis seit 1991 nach dem saudi
arabien preiskrieg loos tritt die
ölpreise erlitten am montag einen
historischen einbruch nachdem saudi
arabien den markt mit einem preiskrieg
gegen den ehemaligen verbündeten
russland schotte
[Musik]
den markt wird über schwämmen angesichts
eines möglicherweise beispiellosen
rückgangs der weltweiten nachfrage mutet
aus ökonomischer sicht eher seltsam an
sicherlich könnte man argumentieren dass
aramco damit einen weiteren rückgang des
verbrauchs zu verhindern versucht und
damit auch konkurrenten mit höheren
produktionskosten in den ruin treiben
will
es gibt jedoch auch ein anderes motiv
saudi arabien möchte wieder zum wohnen
im ölmarkt aufsteigen russland hat es
mit diesem schachzug schon von platz
zwei verdrängt und jetzt nimmt es die
nummer eins die usa ins visier
darüber aber werden wir euch in einem
anderen video erzählen
für heute reicht uns dies als weiteres
beispiel dafür dass aramco eine
regierung verpflichtet ist der defizite
nicht viel ausmachen und die auch
zunehmend unberechenbar erscheint damit
wurden wir erneut daran erinnert warum
die bewertung des aktienpreises dieses
größten unternehmens der welt nicht an
die ökonomische realität gebunden ist
[Musik]
kurz gesagt dies war die geschichte in
der die saudi arabische regierung
schloss mit der privatisierung ihrer
wertvollsten vermögenswerte zu beginn
aber wird sie womöglich ihre ziele
dennoch irgendwann erreichen und ihre
abhängigkeit vom öl verringern können
wärst du persönlich bereit sein sauer
verdientes geld in ein unternehmen die
aramco zu investieren wie immer sind wir
schon sehr gespannt auf eure antworten
im kommentarbereich jede woche laden wir
frische informative videos für euch hoch
also vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren denn nur so verpasst ihr
keines unserer regelmäßigen updates und
wenn du der meinung bist dass ihr dieses
video etwas gebracht hat
gebt uns bitte einen daumen hoch denn
nichts ist für süßes als teurer likes
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]